he's been ruling my checks for months
there will not be checks written on Sky
News during the election campaign
there's no question of their being
checks on goods going n IG b or g BN i
is there part of if you look at what the
deal is were part of the same customs
territory and in the commons when the
unionists questioned the prime
minister's claims does that commitment
also apply to goods moving from Great
Britain to Northern Ireland if in fact
Italy mr. speaker it doesn't but a
government paper has now confirmed that
checks are unavoidable though will need
to be declarations on goods as they move
from Great Britain to Northern Ireland
but these systems will be electronic and
administered by UK authorities the plan
for implementing the Northern Ireland
protocol reveals some new administrative
processes for traders electronic import
declarations and safety and security
information gathering some new tariffs
not on goods entering Northern Ireland
but a knows destined for the Republic or
EU more broadly and some expansion of
infrastructure at airports and seaports
but not any building of checkpoints at
Wilson's country and Khidr ma they're
passionate about potatoes they export
across the Irish Sea but are more
concerned about material they import we
only bring in material that we can't
source within Northern Ireland but no
doubt there will be increased costs in
terms of time paperwork administration
whatever so it's not Korea well we're
promised unfettered access so that says
is a worry
Boris Johnson agreed Czechs in a
breakthrough meeting with his Irish
counterpart lee over adkar last year but
had been accused of misleading people by
repeatedly claiming there'd be Nam
it seemed inevitable that they would
avoid a hard border on this island by
creating a light touch one right there
in the Irish Sea the government says
that respects Northern Ireland's place
in the UK's customs territory while in
protecting the EU single market the
Northern Ireland Protocol is supposed to
be operational
by January whether there's a trade deal
or not David Blevins Sky News in Belfast